all right welcome to new video
let's go against
dr litago from germany
oh god some weird
modern defense
okay
yeah i saw this idea in a book recently
with queen f3
well he's playing quickly at least
yeah no idea what to make of this
bishop f5
it's hard to believe this is all theory
or something
but maybe it is
okay c2 is hanging this is inconvenient
i'm not sure maybe
bishop f4
i have no real real way to
to cover this oh no then he's also
a bishop h5 maybe this isn't a problem
hmm weird position
weird position
okay he's playing so quickly i need to
catch up a bit
okay good okay this one
okay now i can get back
the pawn on c2
but uh what about d6 here d6
threatening f7 and maybe taking on c7
okay let's try this
i mean i'm pretty sure that what black
played here in this game is
complete crap but
but okay no idea how to refute it uh
what so okay is um
gotten deformed back
i still have this nice pawn on the c
file but this might get lost
yeah it's difficult for me to um
to cover this pawn only with knight b5
this is maybe possible
yeah but not b5 b2 is just hanging
okay let's let's get some development
going here
it takes here rook c8 maybe knight d4
trying to get to b5 after all
also rook c1 but then he just drops back
okay
yeah this is difficult if i lose c7
it will get um get tough
okay i need to get this tempo here
if he now moves the bishop again i might
have rook b1
maybe some counter play against b7
uh maybe this
isn't so bad
um
so now i'm threatening just b6 and if he
takes here
i might even take on on b6
then bishop d5
take here you can you can check there so
i grab this one
okay this is hanging
i tried to get the b7 pawn
somehow trying to
decoys bishop from b7 then i might even
have some
winning chances well uh winning chances
some if i get this pawn without any
difficulty and it's just
just one for white i think
this pawn is just just too strong man
also completely killing his rook so
maybe maybe
so difficult yeah okay
yeah but this should be very strong for
me
i didn't see this one okay i still have
uh
i still have a second c pawn so
check
yeah that's it
black resigns yeah the c pawn
i'm not sure complicated um it looked
it looked difficult for me but
somehow
somewhat hmm okay he played this of
course
ambitiously with bishop d3 c4
okay let's let's check quickly with with
the computer what what what
what bishop d
he wants to go to e4 immediately okay
this makes sense yeah
directly covering b7 and this is a clear
advantage for blackier i believe that
it's easily very believable
okay queen d2 but and now this should be
good right
yeah this is advantage for white and now
computer wants to play bishop b3
yeah exactly c4 yeah these are all
according to the computer and what's got
0.7 or something okay
let's play e5 now
yeah this is tougher maybe it's just
oh rookie one small exacto okay well
okay this is winning now yeah
check of course yeah king d5 was
stronger
i played this too quickly king d4 it's
winning all
also i think but king d5 is just better
on rook e7 king d6 and
it's over he can resign him the d pawn
is
gone anyway but this is
still still completely over i think
should be a winning rook and rook
okay very weird opening so i had
no idea what's what's good there or
whatever
strange game okay with a good end um